we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p here's a call from a
christian democrat take a listen to this
hi david this is Ezekiel from Allen
illness and I'm a Christian Democrat and
I've noticed over the time that shows
like The Young Turks and some others
will say that conservatives don't
understand the Bible which I would agree
with but then they go on to try and
explain that by misrepresenting the
Bible themselves do you think that's an
advantageous strategy or do you think
progressives should work on focusing on
the issues that are clearly outlined by
the Bible and try and push forward with
those ideas yeah I actually don't really
see the Bible as a relevant thing to
politics but that's my biased view I
need to understand the reality that for
a lot of people in this country the
Bible is very relevant and we actually
had on election night I had one person
call in and cite Bible Bible passages in
one particular way in connecting them to
politics in a particular way and then
someone else called in and said hey no I
know about the Bible that other guy
didn't here's the actual way that that
goes I actually think it's a loser's
game
I don't think progressives should engage
on this in any way and you remember when
Barack Obama during a debate in 2008 was
asked about his favorite Bible verse and
I think that we didn't see hey Pat
correct me if I'm wrong did we see
questions about favorite bible verses
during the Trump Hillary debates maybe
maybe there was I don't remember
I certainly hope not I don't know what
Trump's favorite bible verse is I don't
think he'd be able to name one offhand
but it would probably come from 2
Corinthians yes 2 Corinthians are a
source of a lot of enjoyment for Donald
Trump clearly yeah listen I I would look
just like to see us get away from the
Bible at all and not use the Bible as an
adjudicating document at all for
politics and what the right policy is
and what the wrong policy is I think
that for those who are self-described
Christians I think that they can
realistically hold them
selves up to the standard that one would
argue most charitably was established to
by Jesus if that's who they believe to
be their God leader Savior or whatever
but I would like to see politics
completely removed and not even have
these a pissing match is for lack of a
better term about who knows the most
about how politics would align with this
book from the Bible or that book from
the Bible let's just stop the the entire
thing we've got a fantastic bonus show
for you today we are going to talk about
ballot measures across the country we
will have an update on the tech
situation in the studio which will be I
predict this as close to the end of tech
updates it's probably the 11th to the
last tech update so not that many tech
updates coming two ways to get the bonus
show become a member at WWJ in pac-man
com become a patron at patreon.com slash
david pakman show we'll speak to you
then it's a good one today